bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans Science Publique votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat c'est une émission très
particulière que nous vous proposons ce
soir à la hauteur de l'émotion ressenti
hier quand nous avons appris la
disparition de Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il
avait créé Public Sénat c'était en avril
2000 on était resté président pendant 9
ans il était aussi en plus de 15 ans le
présentateur de la mythique émission
Bibliothèque Médicis
bienvenue à bibliothèque medicie cet
entretien du 12 septembre 1994 est entré
dans l'histoire de la Cinquième
République et il a lui-même une longue
histoire
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach passeur de culture
mais aussi et surtout grand interviewer
politique des présidents de la
République au ministre tous se
souviennent du stress qu'il ressentait
face à lui
interview avec lui c'était un match un
combat il avait fouillé le sujet il
connaissait l'interlocuteur mais il
connaissait également toutes les
questions rien lui échappait la
politique la France l'international qui
est très bon connaisseur il était à peu
près en mission
l'interviewer le patron de média l'homme
qui murmurait à l'oreille des présidents
on va rendre hommage à Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach dans une minute dans toute une
première partie d'émission et puis tout
à l'heure notre débat de société sera
consacré à la chute du bio la crise du
bio l'évangue dans la grande
distribution également dans les
enseignes spécialisés le bio trop cher
en période d'inflation longue durée le
bio mal identifié par les consommateurs
perdus dans le maquis des labels le
constat et les solutions ce sera dans
une heure puisque c'est une édition
spéciale de ce sens public que je vous
propose depuis hier les hommages du
monde médiatique et politique sont
rendus à Jean-Pierre Elkabbach et c'est
Marion qui nous raconte
bienvenue à plus d'un demi siècle son
visage et sa voix ont marqué le paysage
audiovisuel français mais aussi les
personnalités politiques qui ont eu
affaire à Jean-Pierre Elkabbach tous
salut aujourd'hui sa pugnacité lors de
ces interviews Nicolas Sarkozy alors
jeune élu rappelle avoir tant espéré
être invité à son micro quand Patrick
canard évoque des interviews en forme
d'épreuve ce que confirme Bruno
Retailleau pour nous quittons interviewé
on savait jamais quel côté la question
elle est tombée il y avait quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de tracts mais c'était
un
interviewer agréable parce que il vous
faisait aller au-delà un peu de
vous-même et j'ai toujours beaucoup
mieux que quand c'est un peu plan
respecté par ses interlocuteurs mais
aussi par ses pairs qui saluent sa
rigueur sa curiosité insatiable
tout à fait étonnante c'était une
pugnacité
très
remarquable et parfois même surprenant
Jean-Pierre était une star et il voulait
être une star c'est sans doute l'une des
premières stars du journalisme français
Michel cotta côtoyé Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach durant toute sa carrière et
cette fille rejette les accusations de
connivence avec les puissants qui ont
parfois visé l'ancien journaliste il
était proche des hommes politiques parce
que il voulait leur tirer des
informations et avec ces informations
interrogée d'autres et faire fructifier
donc je trouve que c'était pas un
journaliste de rupture c'était un
journaliste qui posait des questions
dures parfois très dur à des gens en
attendant les réponses en attendant
d'être le premier sur tel ou telle
nouvelle passionnée par son métier
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach était encore à
l'antenne à 80 ans passées ce qui fait
d'ailleurs dire au président Emmanuel
Macron que c'est un monstre sacré du
journaliste français qui s'en est allé
et on hommage à Jean-Pierre et Cabasse
sur Public Sénat je vous présente mes
invités Frédéric Mitterrand bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue ancien ministre de la
culture et de la communication entre
autres Christopher Baldelli bonsoir vous
êtes le président directeur général de
la Chaîne parlementaire Public Sénat
Perrine tardeau bonsoir la directrice de
l'information de Public Sénat et Mathieu
croissanto bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir
éditorialiste politique on va commencer
peut-être par un souvenir personnel pour
pour chacun d'entre vous Frédéric
Mitterrand spontanément qu'est-ce qui
revient quand vous pensez à Jean-Pierre
mais d'abord ma première chose c'est une
pensée personnelle pour Nicolas avril la
femme à laquelle il était très attaché
et qui est une écrivaine délicieuse et
pour qui doit ressentir peut-être encore
plus que nous le manque d'un homme
pareil
moi personnellement je l'ai connu quand
je faisais mes émissions historiques de
vulgarisation et j'étais donc en quelque
sorte assez peu importante et et en même
temps comme il était cultivé qui sentait
que je travaillais beaucoup sur ces
émissions il était très aimable et très
gentil ensuite j'ai travaillé sous ces
ordres à France Télévisions et c'était
moins facile il pouvait être un peu
rugueux oui il pouvait être pour être
rugueux et ça se passait moins bien et
ensuite pour toutes sortes de raisons et
ensuite lorsque je suis venu le voir
dans cette même chaîne à publique Sénat
pour les émissions littéraires alors là
c'était un enchantement
il lisait les livres il aimait la
littérature il était extrêmement
instruit et cultivé et puisqu'il y avait
plus aucune raison ni de commandement à
mon égard ni de compétition de quelque
sorte il était adorable Christopher bald
c'était un grand patron média il y a
plein de qualificatifs qui viennent et
voilà pour vous c'est peut-être celui-là
qui ressort en premier bien sûr mais en
le voyant avec cette écharpe qui était
une de ces images et marques de fabrique
vous vous un petit souvenir
personnel
le ministre de la culture de l'époque
était président de France Télévisions
réunit quelques personnes dont lui pour
faire un grand point sur la télévision
publique etc et je me souviens que
c'était installé un peu au fond de la
salle je vais passer toute une partie de
la réunion avec l'écharpe devant son
visage et en fait il était au téléphone
et en fait je pense qu'il y avait aussi
de ça dans Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
c'est-à-dire une certaine liberté le
fait d'être toujours sur la balle
toujours en train de faire quelque chose
et finalement son rapport avec les
puissant qui était plus ambiguë que je
compense ça pouvait donner beaucoup
d'interprétations Perrine Carnot on va
remonter aux souvenirs de la création de
Public Sénat qu'est-ce qui vous revient
quand la chaîne démarre c'est c'est lui
le c'est le patron le Fondateur de la
chaîne il y a quoi il y a une énergie
c'est quoi le mot qui veut il y a une
énergie formidable un enthousiasme fou
et surtout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que ça faisait déjà une dizaine d'années
qui se battait pour créer cette chaîne
parlementaire il avait fallu convaincre
les parlementaires qui n'avaient pas
forcément envie de faire rentrer les
caméras surtout ici au Sénat où c'était
une institution encore très fermée et
donc il s'est battu pendant une dizaine
d'années pour cette chaîne émerge et
puis après il avait vraiment beaucoup
d'ambition pour publique sonore pour la
chaîne parlementaire il avait été voir
aux États-Unis au Canada il existait
là-bas déjà des chaînes parlementaires
donc il avait fait plusieurs voyages aux
États-Unis pour examiner un peu ce
modèle de chaîne parlementaire et il
voulait faire la même chose créer la
même chose en France ouvrir les
institutions faire la pédagogie sur le
bicamélisme et ça avait été important
pour lui aussi de donner autant de place
au Sénat qu'à l'Assemblée nationale et
ça c'est ce qui avait consacré la loi de
1999 qui a créé la chaîne c'est de
donner autant de place au sénateur
qu'aux député Mathieu croissanto
évidemment 60 ans de carrière c'était
des plus grands connaisseurs de notre
vie politique tout simplement vous avez
bosser avec lui aussi en France c'est un
énorme bosseur moi ce qui me revient
c'est en première image on parlera de la
technique de l'interview tout à l'heure
mais c'est le côté artisanal moi j'ai eu
la chance de faire des interviews le
dimanche avec lui personnalités
politiques pendant 2 ans avec le moi je
travaillais au Parisien et lui il
travaille à repas et à chaque fois que
je rentrais dans son bureau le dimanche
matin c'était un amas de Fish des
stabilos absolument partout donc des
fiches
imprimées mais sur lesquels ils avaient
tout rayé tout réécrit et c'était un
artisan enfin il y avait quelque chose
de de du travail de de l'écrivain du
metteur en scène on en parlera mais
voilà c'était une petite PME à lui tout
seul avec sa fidèle assistante qui
répondait à toutes ces questions il
était là avec sa doudoune hiver comme
été une petite doudoune qui mettait sous
sa veste c'était très chic et le côté
frileux quand même et voilà et c'était
vraiment de artisanat et je garde cette
image là à côté de ça évidemment c'est
le personnage qu'on a décrit ce monstre
du journalisme politique qui a
interviewé huit présidents de la
République qui a interview à peu près
tout le personnel politique qui avait
ses chouchous qui avait les gens qui
n'aimaient pas et ça se sentait quand
même très très vite parce qu'on côtoyait
les politiques à chaque fois avant
l'interview donc ça se sentait dans le
regard mais il avait toujours sous son
sourcil broussailleux le regard qui
s'allumait avec une volonté de faire un
coup ou de faire des coups à chaque fois
il y avait un côté un peu gamin par
moment mais qui était très agréable on y
reviendra sur ses qualités interviewer
politiques on reste sur la création de
de Public Sénat et c'est Gérard Larcher
qui s'en souvient vous êtes à
l'interviewer tout à l'heure Perrine on
est donc le 25 avril 2000
je voudrais rendre hommage au créateur
de Public Sénat loi de 1999 le printemps
2000 Public Sénat première émission et
alors au-delà tout simplement de rendre
compte de l'activité parlementaire il
est président de Public Sénat qui veut
aussi faire partager aux Français ce
qu'est le rôle du Parlement et notamment
du Sénat Sénat beaucoup plus méconnu à
l'époque et dont le rôle était essentiel
dans la fabrication de la loi et je dois
dire que quelque part il a rendu service
à la démocratie et à la démocratie
parlementaire il a fait en bousculant
parfois les codes y compris dans une
maison qui a des codes et je dois dire
que quelque part je veux le remercier
d'avoir bouleversé un certain nombre de
codes c'était pas évident effectivement
au départ la création de la chaîne
il a démarré comme oui précis dans le
scepticisme général moi j'étais au
bureau je pensais que c'était important
parce que je bouddie d'un patience je
brouille toujours aujourd'hui alors
voyez 24 ans avant comment on pouvait
être
et puis il a fait une extraordinaire
émission quand même qui était
Bibliothèque Médicis où ce il a
accueilli des hommes et des femmes dans
cet extraordinaire bibliothèque du Sénat
où il nous a appelé à nous élever et il
a contribué aussi à nous élever les uns
les autres mais il a vraiment rendu à la
service à la démocratie parlementaire
voilà vraiment le message et j'aurai
l'occasion en séance de l'exprimer tout
à l'heure on reste sur ce sur le grand
patron de média évidemment il y a eu
Public Sénat il y a eu France
Télévisions Christopher Baldi il y a eu
Europe 1 qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire de
ce sens de diriger finalement c'est vrai
que pour le grand public et on l'a vu
dans tous les hommages qui sont rendus
on parle beaucoup plus du journalisme du
grand journaliste du Grand interview
politique mais Jean-Pierre a aussi
parallèlement effectivement vous l'avez
dit une une carrière de grande
dirigeants de médias il a été le
président de France Télévisions il a été
celui de Public Sénat durant presque 10
ans et puis il a été celui de de
ce qui me frappait c'est que moi j'ai
toujours fréquenté soit durant ces
périodes ont été dirigeants moi-même
comme comme dirigeant et en fait soit
vous travaillez avec lui soit vous étiez
son concurrent dans une certaine oui
d'une certaine façon et ce qui m'a
toujours frappé chez le dirigeant ce qui
faisait à la fois ses qualités et
parfois il faut le dire c'est défauts
l'homme est humain c'est qu'il avait au
fond un peu les mêmes qualités que comme
journaliste c'est à dire énormément
d'énergie de volonté de faire différents
etc et je vais vous donner une anecdote
quand il dirigeait France Télévisions à
un moment donné il était parti sur le
projet c'était le début de la télévision
par satellite de faire également un
bouquet satellitaire payant et je lui
avais dit mais Jean-Pierre vous avez
déjà France Télévisions vous allez pas
encore plus faire Canal+ les deux en
même temps et c'était assez révélateur
de ce qui était le fameux Ozon qui a été
ensuite caricaturé par les Guignols mais
c'était quand même sa démarche de
dirigeants et un dirigeant qui ose qui
entreprend évidemment ça marche pas
toujours il en a fait des frais un
certain nombre de cas mais dans l'autre
sens apporte quelque chose et sur Public
Sénat par exemple sur France Télévision
évidemment mais sur Public Sénat je
crois que c'est son audace le président
Larcher le rappelait qui a fait que
cette chaîne est bien née et que tout de
suite elle s'est imposée c'était pas
facile dans une institution à l'origine
comme le Sénat elle Perrine des coups
des premières des il y avait un côté
pionnier quoi exactement comme on
n'avait pas du tout d'argent surtout au
départ on en est toujours pas très très
riche au Public Sénat mais quand même au
départ on n'avait pas du tout d'argent
et c'est vrai qu'il fallait donc du coup
entreprendre oser innover il fallait
avoir de l'audace quoi et donc il a eu
effectivement comme ça du flair pour
faire des premières on a été la première
chaîne à diffuser en intégralité les
congrès des partis politiques à l'époque
ça n'existait pas puis après les chaînes
d'infos ont continué ont été créés et ce
sont engouffrés dans dans la brèche mais
donc on a été les premiers à montrer
comment tous les classiques du PS se
batailler batailler entre eux on a été
également les premiers à diffuser en
direct et en intégralité une primaire
parti politique c'était celle du Parti
socialiste qui opposait à l'époque
Ségolène Royal Laurent Fabius et
Dominique Strauss-Kahn en 2006 donc
avant la présidentielle de 2007 donc il
y a eu comme ça un certain nombre de
coups parce qu'on avait du temps on
avait du temps d'antenne on avait pas de
publicité on n'avait pas d'achat de
programme lourd à diffuser et donc on a
pu comme ça inventer un certain nombre
de choses Mathieu croissanto retour aux
souvenirs d'interview commune est-ce que
c'était évident de lui imposer des
thèmes à Jean-Pierre et cabassement
c'était son interview et les politiques
étaient chez lui aussi c'est-à-dire que
Jean-Pierre avait cette cette incroyable
capacité à s'imposer déjà il était
imposant on avait du respect pour pour
son parcours mais on était chez lui
alors moi il me testait toujours
j'arrivais il me faisait croissants
d'eau c'est quoi la première question
je propose un thème n'importe quoi voilà
et puis il a fait ça deux trois fois
puis un moment je veux dire on va
arrêter Jean-Pierre le bizutage parce
que plutôt me dire la première question
on va en parler voilà puisque tu as
choisi parce que tout était préparé tout
était scénarisé un mot de jouer allez
la première c'est que on a entendu là
que il lui arrivait d'être rude il est
érude mais c'est le meilleur service
qu'on puisse rendre à un homme politique
que d'être rude à partir de ce moment-là
un interview mou gentil etc n'en sort
rien un interview rude ça permet à un
homme politique de se définir plus
fortement et les hommes politiques qui
ne l'aimaient pas mettaient souvent pas
de très grande qualité ceux de très
grande qualité appréciées et même et
même Georges Marchais dont on sait à
quel point il était en quelque sorte un
partenaire en fait il estimait
Elkabbache la deuxième chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que moi j'aime pas
du tout l'info spectacle c'est-à-dire le
crâne de chanson une animatrice l'Irak
de chansons et animatrice et un type qui
fait rigoler entre temps en revanche
avec Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il y a eu la
création en France d'un journaliste qui
installait le spectacle du dialogue avec
sa dureté avec ses conflits avec ces
difficultés il y avait peut-être quelque
part une sorte de souvenirs de Larry
King qui avait ça aux États-Unis pendant
des années d'une manière très très
brillante mais c'était beaucoup mieux
que la rything parce qu'il était
infiniment plus cultivé que l'été la
réquine alors la scénarisation des
interviews ça on va on va en dire un mot
je vous donne la parole juste après
Perrine ternaux mais il y a tellement
dommage de témoignages qu'on a pu
recueillir en cette dans cette journée
je voudrais essayer de tous les partager
avec vous tiens celui d'un autre grand
patron de média Philippe Labro l'un de
vos prédécesseurs à la tête de RTL alors
lui on va remonter là aussi dans le
temps il se souvient du tout jeune
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il l'avait eu sous
ses ordres à Radio France pendant la
guerre d'Algérie FIP Labro
pendant la guerre d'Algérie moi j'avais
été détaché de l'armée j'ai pardon pour
diriger
la rédaction de
l'antenne de Français de France de Radio
France et la télé parce que il y avait
plus personne donc on allait chercher
les gens qui avaient déjà un peu un
métier dans les casernes pour qu'ils
exercent ce métier et donc j'avais sous
ma direction j'avais à peine 24 ans
toutes sortes de correspondants dont
l'un d'entre eux était à Oran et qui
s'appelait kabache j'ai toujours le
souvenir je l'ai gardé sur mon agenda un
jour j'avais écrit Elkabbache point
d'exclamation et ça voulait dire que
déjà à l'époque il se distinguait des
autres qui étaient d'ailleurs un peu
compliqué parfois à traiter et à gérer
mais pour moi c'est ça c'est point
d'exclamation Jean-Pierre point
d'exclamation Jean-Pierre il a donc
découvert sa passion pour le journaliste
en 1960 c'est lors d'un stage à Radio
Alger point de départ d'une
impressionnante carrière longue de plus
de 60 ans Fabien Ricard
une histoire de la télévision française
à lui tout seul homme de radio dirigeant
de médias interviewer politique
Jean-Pierre Elkabbache se décrivait
d'abord comme un journaliste un
journaliste précis provocateur quand il
le faut quand on interroge ou on
rencontre des gens qui parlent partout
les grands dirigeants internationaux ce
boulimique de travail les aura tous
interrogé au fil de sa carrière né à
Oran 1937 il quitte l'Algérie son bac en
poche et fait ses débuts dans le
journalisme en 1961 dans les années 70
l'émission carte sur table renouvelle le
genre de l'interview politique avec
Georges Marchais où Jacques Chirac
dépasse d'armes restés célèbres
c'est tout à fait inutile
pas à vous mettre dans votre petite tête
que moi aussi j'ai un cerveau et un
cerveau qui est capable de raisonner de
réfléchir et de formuler des
propositions et des appréciations et
vincer du service public après
l'élection de François Mitterrand il
affirme avoir été viré à la demande du
pouvoir François Mitterrand lui
accordera pourtant son ultimate
interview en 1994 dans quel cas vous
diriez c'est le Président Monsieur
Mitterrand vous vous direz j'arrête je
pars je peux pas continuer
la souffrance
est-elle que qu'elle
pèse sur moi au point que je ferai
passer l'examen de mon sort dans celui
des devoirs d'état éphémère président de
France Télévisions au milieu des années
90 Jean-Pierre Elkabbach se consacre
ensuite à la création d'une chaîne un
genre nouveau 3 2
1 en l'an 2000 publics Sénat voit le
jour l'aboutissement d'une longue
bataille pour faire tomber les
réticences des sénateurs à laisser
entrer les caméras au Palais du
Luxembourg
de travail
la presse un outil démocratique pour les
institutions pour approcher le citoyen
de ces élus des politiques et donner une
autre image du politique sur la chaîne
dont il restera président jusqu'en 2009
ce passionné de littérature anime une
émission littéraire à sa mesure
Bibliothèque Médicis dont il conservent
les reines au-delà de son mandat
jusqu'en 2017 pilier d'Europe 1
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach poursuit son
activité d'interviewer politique jusqu'à
l'âge de 85 ans tyrannique selon
certains critiqués pour sa proximité
supposée avec Nicolas Sarkozy
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach aura passé 6
décennies derrière le micro une
longévité record pour cette infatigable
du journalisme politique
d'interview poétique Perrine tarno c'est
quoi le conseil que vous avez retenu la
première question peut-être je pense
qu'on a tous reçu à peu près le même
conseil c'est effectivement l'accroche
la première question toujours très
importante et puis surtout faire des
questions courtes
vraiment ne pas lui il avait le droit
mais vraiment il fallait faire des
questions courtes ça c'était le Conseil
majeur et puis bosser bosser préparer
voilà il y avait vraiment tout un
système de préparation en amont fallait
jamais rien laisser passer donc il y
avait une scénarisation racontez-nous
parce que c'était c'était un metteur en
scène intéressant l'extrait qu'on a vu
des missions car sur table et avec un
duel parce qu'il m'avait raconté je sais
plus c'est un duel qu'ils avaient choisi
une toute petite table dans un grand
studio pour être à portée de gifle en
gros pour créer tout de suite une
tension avec avec leur interlocuteur et
Jean-Pierre il consommait ses interviews
vraiment comme une pièce de théâtre
c'est à dire qu'il y avait l'entrée en
scène avec la première question la
fameuse
la seconde question qui était tout aussi
importante et ces deux questions avaient
pour vocation de créer un rapport de
force immédiat avec l'invité c'est un
mélange de boxe et d'échecs les deux les
deux premières questions vous mettez un
coup au foie et un coucher du gauche à
votre invité du coup voilà il est posé
il aussi des chez Jean-Pierre et ensuite
on déroulait et on joue aux échecs on
avançait les pions et qu'est-ce que
c'était avancer les pions c'est à dire
que comme tout quand on prépare une
interview évidemment on prépare les
questions on dit quel thème on va
aborder comme ci comme ça mais avec
Jean-Pierre on poussait l'exercice à
répéter les questions comment nous
allions les formuler et puis à imaginer
la réponse de l'invité et on se disait
s'il nous répond ça on lui dit ça s'il
nous répond ça on lui dit si et donc
tout se déroulait comme ça comme
incroyable répétition et alors ensuite
l'interview ne ressemblait pas forcément
à la pièce qui avait été créée mais il
restait de cette trame des réflexes un
jeu plus ou moins improvisé mais qui
était extraordinairement efficace en
termes de d'interview et d'ailleurs on
retrouvait dans les fiches qu'il
préparait pour ses interviews il y avait
il séparait toujours la page en deux et
la colonne avec les questions et la
colonne avec les réponses possibles et
donc tout était effectivement scénarisé
c'est ça qui est intéressant il
imaginait tout ce qui pouvait
effectivement être possible alors on est
en duplex avec André valligny ancien
ministre ancien sénateur de de de
l'Isère je vais vous donner la parole
tout de suite mais on va revoir une
archive ensemble mai 2014 vous êtes
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
réforme territoriale la première
question que vous pose Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach c'est ça
quelle couleur vous préférez pour le mur
pour le mur quel mur
comment qu'elle mûr le mur sur lequel
votre réforme territoriale va se
fracasser
on réveille il commence remède une telle
entrée en matière sur le ring de boxe
il faut se remettre très vite
debout parce que c'est vrai que la
première question comme souvent les
premières questions de Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach c'est le premier question m'a
totalement décontenancée pendant une
seconde une seconde et demi je me suis
demandé ce qui s'était passé sur un mur
quelqu'un c'est ce que j'avais pu dire
ou faire ou ce qui s'était passé dans la
nuit qui m'aurait échappé en fait
j'étais totalement totalement abasourdi
par la par la question et puis ensuite
bon au bout de une seconde et demi à peu
près il m'a dit que c'était le mur sur
lequel elle se fracassait la réforme
territoire mais justement ça me permet
de revenir sur ce que disait à l'instant
Perrine Tarnaud et Mathieu croissanto
tout était scénarisé c'est-à-dire que il
vous appelez la veille à 22h à peu près
après que Marie Moreau sa fidèle
assistante vous est prévenu à 18h qui
vous prendrait le lendemain à vers 22h
et que vous appelez et il commençait à
scénariser l'interview on continuait le
lendemain matin à 7h45 dans son bureau
parce que l'interview est à 8h20 donc
tout était bien préparé sans connivence
aucune mais il voulait vraiment qu'il
sorte quelque chose de l'interview et ce
que disait aussi tout à l'heure Frédéric
Mitterrand est très juste c'est à dire
que il nous disait si vous dites des
choses si vous sentez de l'eau tiède
personne ne retiendra rien il y aura pas
de reprise il y aura pas de dépêche à FP
donc il nous incitait avec beaucoup
d'insistance et de bienveillance à dire
des choses assez fortes mais c'est assez
étonnant ce que vous décrivez parce que
il y a à la fois beaucoup de préparation
et la surprise de la première question
c'est à dire que vous saviez que de
toute façon il y aurait une première
question un peu coup de poing quasi
impossible à anticiper
oui c'est ça oui c'est doudou l'anxiété
la nuit qui précédait les interviews
avec Elkabbach on dormait pas très bien
moi j'ai fait plusieurs fois Europe 1 à
8h20 avec lui c'était toujours une
épreuve c'était c'était un moment dont
on savait par avance qui serait
difficile mais si on s'en sortait pas
trop mal c'était plutôt positif donc
fallait pas il fallait pas redouter d'y
aller il fallait y aller d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'hommes politiques rêvaient
d'être invités par elkaba évidemment
mon premier interview quand je faisais
des émissions de télévision je vous dis
inoffensive comme ça c'était avec lui et
j'avais été très très mauvais et ça a
été une leçon formidable pour moi parce
que je dis pas que je suis devenu
meilleur mais quand même j'avais à peu
près compris le fonctionnement je
voudrais rajouter une chose c'était la
langue telle Cabasse je parlais un
Français magnifique et la forme
interrogative qui a disparu maintenant
la météo c'est quoi non ça existe pas on
faire comme ça la forme interrogative il
l'a pratiqué parfaitement et le fait de
poser des questions brèves ne l'empêchez
pas de parler un français formidable ce
qui d'une certaine manière stimuler
forcément ses interlocuteurs parce
qu'ils seront des comptes qui s'étaient
en face de quelqu'un qui était quand
même une grande dimension et par
ailleurs simuler le véritable talent
populaire de quelqu'un comme George
marchais évidemment Mathieu il avait en
plus cette technique qui n'appartient en
fait qu'à lui je trouve dans le paysage
médiatique ça a été parfois imité mais
moins bien et qu'il poussait son
interlocuteur dans ses retranchements en
pot en n’hésitant pas poser parfois 4 5
fois la même question dans un exemple ou
dans les médias anglo-saxons mais un
ministre dit ben on va faire mais quand
donc le ministre continue voilà mais
quand mais quand quand et au bout de la
cinquième fois voilà et combien voilà
vous allez faire des mesures combien
combien et donc au bout d'un moment il
devait sortir quelque chose et pour les
politiques c'est vrai que beaucoup le
redoutait parce que c'était pas
forcément un bon moment à passer mais il
faut savoir aussi que c'était un
adoument faire Elkabbache quand vous
démarriez en politique c'était que vous
aviez atteint la première division avant
vous êtes en ligue de c'était que vous
comptez pas puis à cette époque-là vous
faites Elkabbache il y avait en gros
vous avez deux incontournables dans dans
Ludovic dans l'audiovisuel il y avait
Jean-Pierre et puis il y avait il y a eu
lors de vérité un moment il y a eu Anne
Sinclair avec 7 sur 7 à d'autres mais
c'était des rendez-vous quand vous étiez
politiques vous étiez obligés d'avoir
coché ces cases vous ne pouviez pas
exister sans avoir été d'une certaine
façon adouée par Jean-Pierre et le
cavache et si vous réinvitez pas si vous
aviez été trop mauvais dès qu'il sortait
une interview j'ai est-ce qu'il y a eu
des dépêches est-ce qu'il y a eu des
dépêches tout de suite pour savoir s'il
y avait les reprises et ben vous aviez
peu de chance d'être invité très très
souvent on peut rajouter à l'Indus Amel
évidemment évidemment sur RTL une
dernière question André Vallier est-ce
que vous avez reparlé avec lui après de
ce fameux mur
après j'ai été à la Francophonie et il
s'intéressait beaucoup comme l'a dit
Frédéric Mitterrand à la langue
française à la littérature il était très
cultivé Mitterrand était aussi donc
quand je le voyais régulièrement puis je
reviens encore récemment à la projection
du film de Bernard-Henri Lévis sur
l'Ukraine et il y avait Nicolas abri
avec lui et Nicolas brille m'a dit vous
savez j'ai beaucoup disputé Jean-Pierre
à cause de la question sur le mur il a
pas été gentil avec vous mais moi je dis
mais non c'est pas grave au contraire
elle Cabasse je suis ajouté mais non ça
l'a fait connaître au contraire ça l'a
aidé dans sa carrière donc non non
plaisantait tous les deux bien sûr merci
beaucoup André Vallini d'avoir témoigné
dans ce dans cette émission spéciale cet
hommage à Jean-Pierre Elkabbach on
parlait d'Alain Duhamel donc qui a
co-animé avec lui cette émission carte
sur table c'était sur Antenne 2 à
l'époque
Alain Duhamel il parle lui aussi de
cette dramaturgie écoute
il était un dramaturge et il se vivait
comme tel et préparait ses interviews de
cette façon là il avait une façon une
manière
unique je dis pas ça parce qu'il est
mort mais c'était la réalité de dès
qu'il pénétrer dans un studio et qu'il
avait un interlocuteur brusquement on
avait l'impression qu'on était à la fin
de d'un opéra de Wagner que tout allait
sauter autour de nous et alors en plus
pour tous ceux qui font de la radio ça
veut dire à quelque chose de précis
quand il avait commencé son interview il
ne fallait pas espérer qu'il la
terminale heure il fallait toujours
qu'il grimpait du temps
Christopher Baldelli quand vous étiez
patron de RTL Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
était encore l'interviewer politique de
d'Europe 1 pendant plusieurs années
est-ce que ça vous est arrivé d'être
jaloux des coûts qu'il réussissait
oui bien sûr il y avait notamment un
coup fameux il était parti à Moscou pour
avoir une interview exclusive de
déjà de l'argent
et là c'était Poutine donc oui ça
c'était il y avait que lui qui savait
faire ça après on avait aussi de très
bons interviews sur RTL à l'époque
notamment Jean-Michel Apathie et on a
évoqué quelque chose sur le côté à
l'américaine qui ne se faisait pas en
France de répéter la question jusqu'au
moment où la personne en face soit
donner une réponse soit n'en donnez pas
ce qui était une réponse Jean-Michel
Apathie a aussi beaucoup pratiqué ça
même
c'est pas factice ça pour vous avec
Mitterrand le fait de reposer parce que
ça peut être ça peut être un peu de
justement de politique spectacle de
faire ça de la journée
je suis un interview ouvert tendre j'ai
toujours envie de mettre en valeur la
personne qui est en face de moi et pas
avec des questions rudes donc je sais
pas je suis pas très bon dans ce jeu là
quoique il m'est arrivé quelquefois
d'être de savoir mais aussi un petit peu
ce qui est tout à fait extraordinaire on
revient sur l'idée de la Rikki tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire que effectivement
il ne lâchait pas
et ça c'était
c'était génial à voir oui c'était une
ténacité qui était incroyable mais on
parlait de l'interview de Poutine il a
été au moins trois fois à Moscou pour
essayer de décrocher lui-même pour
essayer de décrocher cette interview il
avait interviewé effectivement
Gorbatchev aussi au moment de la
pérestroika et il nous avait raconté que
il avait été dans tous les pays d'Europe
de l'Est au moment où voilà le régime
communiste s'effondrait pour essayer de
tisser des liens d'aller interviewer
chacun des nouveaux responsables qui
émergés et donc avoir cette fameuse
interview de Gorbatchev donc il ne
lâchait jamais rien et notamment à
l'international parce que la politique y
avait la politique nationale qui est le
passionné mais la politique
internationale l'intéressait également
très fortement alors sur cette aspect
sur la politique internationale
justement je vous propose un autre
témoignage celui d'Emmanuel guicher qui
est aujourd'hui directrice de l'antenne
et des programmes de Public Sénat qui a
longtemps travaillé avec Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach à Europe 1 ou à France
Télévisions Emmanuel
tu es quelqu'un qui s'intéressait qui
était curieux de tout il savait ce que
c'était quatre journalistes pour lui
cette définition c'était être curieux de
tous intéressés à la culture à la
littérature à la société et
effectivement à l'actualité
internationale moi j'ai commencé à
travailler avec lui en 1988 à Europe 1
et c'était cette période qui était très
très
singulière de la fin des pays de l'est
donc on a voyagé on a rencontré
Gorbatchev jérusaleski qui a enlevé ses
lunettes pour parler en direct à
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il a il a vu
Arafat plusieurs fois ce qui lui a été
d'ailleurs parfois reproché par la
communauté juive c'était quelqu'un qui
voulait pas se laisser enfermer dans un
carpent et finalement ça lui plaisait
beaucoup aussi d'être
considéré comme un égal de certains
grands écrivains il avait cette
appétence pour pour sortir du champ un
peu un peu rétréci on pouvait réduire le
journaliste politique
c'est à dire qu'il achète pas quoi il
pouvait
convaincre une personnalité politique ou
autre de participer à une de ses
émissions ça pouvait durer des semaines
ou des mois il pouvait effectivement ne
pas lâcher une personnalité française
pour pour avoir l'interview il avait
aussi ce dont donc il avait cette
ténacité mais il avait aussi ce dont
pour faire émerger des personnalités
nouvelles donc il était dur dans ces
interviews mais effectivement il a aussi
donné beaucoup de chance à des nouveaux
talents que ce soit des journalistes ou
des hommes ou femmes politiques
françaises je pense par exemple à ramaya
qui a travaillé ici au Sénat qui l'a
fait connaître qui après est devenu
secrétaire d'État de Nicolas Sarkozy il
est un des premiers à l'avoir découvert
et à l'avoir fait émergé sur la scène
politique française donc ça pour ça il
avait beaucoup de fleurs est-ce que
parce que vous avez été en concurrence
ou vous avez participé à des discussions
qui pouvaient regrouper des patrons de
médias est-ce qu'il était dur en
affaires si j'ose dire
cette ténacité là est-ce qu'on la
retrouvait quand il défendait le
brouillard c'était surtout beaucoup de
volonté je dirais que ça principal
qualité en aussi comme dirigeant c'était
beaucoup de volonté mais la vie d'un
homme n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille au moment où on parle de la
disparition de quelqu'un surtout
quelqu'un de son talent qui a occupé la
scène durant aussi longtemps on ne voit
que l'or les lumières etc or dans la vie
n'est pas toujours aussi talentueux
quelqu'un soit-il la vie n'est pas une
comédie la vie est aussi parfois une
tragédie et mon voisin Frédéric
Mitterrand a sur beaucoup montré des
tragédies formidables dans des vies qui
a priori des vies royales impériales qui
avaient tout pour être heureuse mais si
je reviens à Jean-Pierre Elkabbache il
faut aussi se souvenir et ça faisait
partie de l'homme c'est que comme
dirigeant d'entreprises il a eu des
revers très sévères il a dû démissionner
de France Télévisions bon public Sénat
ça a été une histoire heureuse pour lui
mais ensuite Europe 1 l'histoire a été
beaucoup plus courte que ce qu'il
pouvait espérer
pourquoi ça a été plus court que ça je
ne sais pas il faut demander il faut
demander aux dirigeants de l'époque mais
Jean-Pierre était depuis tellement
longtemps un repas avait fait tellement
de choses à repas que tout le monde
savait que son désir était sans doute à
un moment donné de diriger au repas et
quand il est enfin atteint ce Graal de
mémoire ça n'a pas duré si longtemps que
ça et ça n'a pas non plus été un chemin
de rose il a rencontré un certain nombre
de difficile de difficultés
sa jeunesse en Algérie la guerre
d'Algérie la guerre d'Algérie la mort de
son père il a une destruction quand il
avait 12 ans la destruction de tous ceux
pour quoi il avait été éduqué et fait
et je pense que
hérite survivant d'un brasier en quelque
sorte il était dans la vie comme une
sorte de pompier c'est à dire qu'il nous
disait la faut regarder là il faut
regarder là il se passe quelque chose et
je pense mais profondément que c'est une
des une des raisons pour lesquelles il a
été tellement exceptionnel tellement
différent des autres puisqu'il avait
pour utiliser un terme qu'on en utilise
toujours à tort et à travers mais il
avait il avait un vécu incroyable ce qui
explique aussi cette résilience cette
capacité à surmonter tous les coups du
sort chaque fois qu'on disait
Elkabbache fini terminé on le retrouvait
presque immédiatement soit l'antenne
soit au micro à une capacité de
résilience ou de rebondir
c'est qu'il avait effectivement été
évidemment très marquée par la mort de
son père un 3 octobre comme lui un 3
octobre il est mort lui aussi un 3
octobre donc le même jour que son père
et cette coïncidence je trouve est
extraordinaire
et c'est vrai quand il a perdu son père
à 12 ans
il est resté chez lui comme une forme
d'obsession un petit peu de la mort
c'était vraiment un sujet qui était très
fort chez lui qui l'a beaucoup
aussi inspiré dans la conduite de
certains ces entretiens je pense à ceux
avec François Mitterrand à la fin de sa
vie
cette thématique de la mort était
quelque chose de très prégnant chez lui
le côté résilient de de Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach Christopher Baldi jouet qu'on
parle justement de de cette période
France Télévisions l'affaire des
animateurs producteurs c'est comme ça
qu'on l'a qu'on l'a appelé on lui
reproche d'avoir donné beaucoup trop
d'argent aux animateurs producteurs vous
l'avez vécu de l'intérieur cette affaire
oui effectivement il y a eu disons le
chemin de gloire et ensuite le Chopin de
de Damas le chemin de gloire c'est qu'il
arrive il rêvait de ça ils étaient deux
d'ailleurs grand journaliste Jean-Marie
Cavada ou si à l'époque il y avait et
puis c'est lui qui a télévision France
Télévisions comme aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose de considérable moins de
chaîne qu'aujourd'hui mais des chaînes
extrêmement puissantes et là ils mènent
une politique à la Jean-Pierre et
cabbach osons aux gens fait un truc
incroyable en moins d'un an il réunit
les plus grands animateurs il en pic à
TF1 il en découvre d'autres et qui ont
tous une particularité beaucoup de
talents Jean-Luc Delarue Arthur ils
l'ont montré depuis mais qui viennent
dans des conditions qui sont pas
nécessairement les conditions
financières qu'on peut avoir sur sens
public sur pardon sur le Service Public
Sénat et sur le service public qui
viennent avec ce que docker ont appelé
des ponts d'or ce que d'autres ont
appelé de façon un peu excessive les
voleurs de patates oui ce qui est
évidemment plutôt quand on est sur le
service public que sur une scène privée
parce que je pense qu'il avait une vraie
ambition où il a montré d'ailleurs sa
réussite en termes d'audience en termes
d'image il a redonné une formidable
dynamique au service public si je peux
vous interrompre pour conclure
l'anecdote mais à l'époque j'étais à TF1
et c'est la période où l'écart entre le
20 de TF1 et celui de France 2 et le
plus serré et je peux vous dire qu'à TF1
il y avait du de la réflexion des toutes
les recettes possibles pour essayer de
faire en sorte que le venteur de France
est tout à fait ne passe pas devant
c'est tout à fait exact et donc derrière
cette réussite formidable et cette
action de dirigeant il était c'est la
première fois qu'ils se retrouvait
dirigeant de quelque chose et il a fait
quelques certainement
maladresse
imprudence voilà et derrière il y a eu
véritablement parce qu'il avait commis
quelques fautes il y a eu véritablement
moi je l'ai vécu de l'intérieur ce que
j'appellerai une cabale c'est-à-dire un
certain nombre de gens différents des
intérêts différents qui tout d'un coup
ce sont coalisés réellement pour le
faire tomber et à l'époque je le
rappelle c'est on nous filme notre
époque aujourd'hui être président de
France Télévisions c'était pas un long
fleuve tranquille puisque son
prédécesseur one ses prédécesseurs sont
prédicaire je crois Philippe Guillaume
j'ai une pensée pour sa famille sa fille
sa femme avait écrit un livre président
abattre parce que lui-même s'était fait
après avoir eu la présidence de France
Télévisions sortir du système par le
pouvoir de l'époque pour Jean-Pierre
Elkabbache ça a été un peu plus complexe
que ça le pouvoir de l'époque il y a en
partie contribué mais c'est d'autres
personnes pour des intérêts divers et
variés qui véritablement
ce sont liés ou en tout cas ce sont
retrouvés et ça a été une chasse à
l'homme et à l'arrivée elle a aboutit à
sa démission et c'était donc extrêmement
violent parce qu'au fond pour lui
c'était un peu le rêve d'une vie et ce
rêve il a vu le bon côté
dans le dynamique formidable qu'il a mis
et puis très vite il a été attaqué
véritablement de façon très forte au
point de devoir démissionner et
finalement les animateurs vecteurs sont
restés et c'est lui qui a dû partir
Cédric Mitterrand est-ce qu'il doit
est-ce qu'il a donné trop d'argent aux
animateurs producteurs est-ce que
c'était une erreur une imprudence une
forme d'injustice dans la cabale qui est
une injustice puisque moi il m'en a pas
donné
en dehors de ça non
il faut bien imaginer ce qui était la
culture européenne ce qui était la
culture de la télévision la culture de
l'information
qui était des choses à la fois très
contrôlée par le pouvoir quel qu'il soit
et en même temps ça crée une certaine
manière à partir du moment où il
bouleversait les équilibres habituels à
partir du moment où il y a porté
peut-être de l'imprudence mais aussi du
panache parce qu'il sait pas trompé il
les a bien choisis les fameuses
animateurs puisqu'ils sont restés donc
il y avait il avait pas tort à partir du
moment où il y a de l'imprudence et du
panache beaucoup de gens vous le
reprochent ceux qui ne font pas
d'imprudence et qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de panache le caractère de Jean-Pierre
Elkabbache ça sa capacité finalement à
se réinventer ou à rebondir après les
les échecs peut-être ça vient aussi du
fait que il était exigeant d'abord avec
lui-même c'était son premier critique
notamment après une interview écoutez
Laurence Ferrari qui se souvient de
l'époque où elle commençait sa carrière
Europe 1 avec Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
c'est vrai que c'est lui qui a influencé
toute une génération de jeunes
journalistes j'en faisais partie je l'ai
rencontré
1989 à Europe 1 c'était déjà un mythe
c'était déjà le grand interviewer du
matin et on était tous à apprendre de ce
qui me faisait il avait une attaque
d'interview qui a servi de modèle à des
générations d'interviewer après lui il
était pugnar s'il était punchy il
cherche toujours la question qui va
perturber qui va déstabiliser qui va
faire en sorte que l'inviter soit un
petit peu hors de ces éléments de
langage donc il a été précurseur
vraiment pour beaucoup d'entre nous oui
il y a une anecdote qui ne me revient en
mémoire j'étais jeune journaliste à
Europa vraiment très très jeune et il
sortait d'une interview du studio je me
rappelle plus c'était un chef d'État
étranger et il n'était pas satisfait
parce qu'il n'était jamais satisfait
d'aucune de ces interviews et il nous
demandait à tous nous les jeunes
journalistes qui étions là à travailler
et qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de mon
interview est-ce que mon attaque était
bonne est-ce que je n'aurais pas dû
commencer par une autre question et
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach c'était le
questionnement permanent c'était il
écoutait ce qu'on disait il écoutait nos
réponses mais au fond il était son
propre juge et il était son pire
critique c'est lui encore une fois qui
était exigeant qui demandait toujours
plus à lui-même alors c'était un
parcours extraordinaire d'abord
effectivement par la qualité et la
quantité de travail qu'il produisait
c'était un travailleur à bosseur
infidèle qu'une interview il l'a
préparait 200 points en amont et il la
refaisait dans sa tête si son point
après c'est surtout ça en fait qui est
le gage de la longévité pour les
journalistes c'est travailler travailler
travailler
Mathieu croissant Deski doutait beaucoup
avant une interview effectivement
Jean-Pierre et cava je trouvais ce que
vous avez pas forcément ressenti il
était pas serein il était pas serein
parce que quand on crée ce climat de
tension bah ça stresse un peu tout le
monde y compris celui qui le crée après
lui il s'en nourrissait pendant
l'interview mais je l'ai jamais vu
détendu au contraire jusqu'au dernier
moment en disant bon alors on est bien
d'accord c'est comme ça enfin il était
oui il était c'est pas quelqu'un qui
doutait au sens je suis pas sûr de moi
voilà mais c'est quelqu'un qui avait
cette exigence de pouvoir se dire au
dernier moment on change et changer ses
invités au dernier moment beaucoup de
politiques ont fait les frais alors
c'était l'actualité qui dictait les
choix les choix de l'invité mais c'était
voilà il était toujours capable au
dernier moment de de changer quelque
chose est-ce que mais je pense que ça
c'était vraiment un de ces traits de
caractère pour ceux qui n'ont connu et
qui ont travaillé avec lui c'est que en
apparence il était toujours très sûr de
lui très affirmatif il y avait pas de
place au doute et en fait on sait que
c'était un peu plus compliqué quand on
le connaissait un petit peu et que
derrière cette apparence qui qui avait
l'air d'être un peu parfois un mur où il
y avait pas de matière à discuter à
argumenter en réalité il était
effectivement en son exigence faisait
sans doute et ça se fait sa force je
crois pas qu'il y ait des gens qui aient
une carrière de cette durée là si ils
sont juste dans dans l'arrogance dans
l'assurance et la première qualité pour
être un bon professionnel journaliste ou
autre c'est toujours d'avoir une part
d'inquiétude et toujours de se remettre
en question et de s'interroger sur ce
qu'on a fait est-ce que c'était bien ce
que c'était pas bien c'était
je pense qu'il y avait aussi un petit
côté un peu Cabot parfois chez
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il est il émet en
jouet voilà c'était une façon un petit
peu aussi de tester de tester les gens
en leur posant des questions et en avoir
en ayant l'air comme ça peu assuré je
pense qu'il était quand même très sûr de
lui et puis quand il a une certaine
habitude c'est une star Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach oui c'est une star mais
effectivement sur de lui mais
mais avec
votre en fait c'est qu'il avait une
sensibilité qui était quand même tourné
vers les autres vers une curiosité je
lui dis tout à l'heure insatiable sur
tous les domaines que ce soit la
littérature la politique française les
questions internationales voilà et donc
c'était ça qui faisait véritablement sa
vraie humanité et est-ce qu'il était
humour il y avait l'humour il y avait
l'humour moi j'ai souvent ri avec
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach après un moment de
très grande assurance tout d'un coup je
sais pas peut-être parce que j'avais un
côté peut-être qu'il amusait mais il
était drôle et et il était sensible au
fait que l'on rit à ses plaisanteries et
ça je dois dire que
c'est pas un aspect que l'on met
souligne souvent et pourtant c'est la
vérité est-ce que c'était un on a
beaucoup parlé de l'interview politique
assez peu de bibliothèques Médicis vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement c'était autre
chose c'était un autre interviewer quand
il faisait cette émission non c'était le
même interviewer mais c'est un
interviewer très très affable là en
l'occurrence parce qu'il était pas en
face de dinosaure de la politique et qui
est quand même se dévorent les uns les
autres toute la journée mais en face
d'écrivain de gens beaucoup plus
fragiles qui venaient en plus pour
défendre leur livre ils ne passait
d'ailleurs pas très souvent sur les
autres émissions et donc en face de
Jean-Pierre escaba s'ils étaient assez
démunis et donc il n'allait pas les il
n'allait pas leur faire du mal bien au
contraire en plus il aimait la
littérature il aimait les livres donc il
invitait des écrivains ou des auteurs ou
des écrivains et des autrices
dont il voulait défendre en quelque
sorte l'oeuvre donc il n'était pas là
pour les il était pas là pour les
contraintes et au contraire pour essayer
de les mettre en confiance ce qui
faisait des émissions tout à fait
remarquables tout à fait remarquable on
avait vraiment envie après l'avoir
entendu de d'acheter le livre dont il
avait parlé de s'intéresser à l'auteur
qu'il avait mis en valeur c'est aussi
pour se s'inscrire dans cette continuité
vous allez vous recréer une mission
littéraire sur l'enseignement absolument
il y a des gens parfois qui
s'interrogent en disant Public Sénat
c'est une chaîne parlementaire une
chaîne civique d'aucunise une chaîne
politique pourquoi faire de la culture
pourquoi faire des émissions littéraires
pour deux raisons et je pense que
l'ancien ministre de la Culture et
l'homme de culture qui est Frédéric
Mitterrand me mentira pas je pense que
la culture fait aussi partie de la
politique dans le bon sens du terme et
au-delà de ça c'est j'ai voulu respecter
cette tradition d'émission littéraire
sur Public Sénat à cause de grâce à
Bibliothèque Médicis effectivement et
aujourd'hui si on regarde l'ensemble des
des chaînes publiques et privées à ma
connaissance il y a plus que deux
émissions strictement émissions
littéraires dont au bonheur des livres
sur le public Sénat et s'il faut dire
juste un mot de cette Bibliothèque
Médicis qui ne s'appelle pas
Bibliothèque Médicis c'est Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach qui l'a rebaptisé c'est
l'annexe de la bibliothèque du Sénat est
à lui absolument formidable c'est un
décor
de il était tout noir pour publique
c'est là c'est c'est un décor absolument
majestueux et quand je suis arrivé je
lui dis bah c'est la bibliothèque ici
c'est pas non pas du tout les gens
l'appelle comme ça à cause enfin grâce à
Jean-Pierre kamache
visionnaire aussi parce qu'il avait su
créer une chaîne parlementaire mais qui
allait au-delà du simple parlementaire
c'est à dire que pour lui c'était faire
vivre la démocratie dans le sens large
du terme c'est englober des
documentaires des débats de société ça
englober effectivement la littérature la
littérature écrite par des écrivains par
des poètes par
[Musique]
je ne dis jamais c'était mieux avant
jamais parce qu'ici dans un Bibliothèque
Médicis un grand qui s'appelait Lucien
cher Fagnon spécialise Saint-Augustin
l'Antiquité était venu présenter un
petit livre c'était mieux avant et il
expliquait que de cicérons et Sénèque
disait déjà c'était mieux avant donc je
le dirai pas mais
je peux dire toutes les grandes choses
que j'ai vécues depuis la décolonisation
il y avait l'URSS il y avait deux
Allemagne il y en a une il n'y avait pas
de téléphone la plus forte raison
portable dans les maisons il veut pas de
téléphone il y avait pas de douche il y
avait pas de voiture autant de voitures
toute la transformation des sociétés de
ceux avec quoi nous vivons ça c'est une
chose mais aujourd'hui dans un monde
certifié mais avec des technologies qui
changent tout aussi
mais chaque époque sa passion le seul
problème c'est d'essayer d'être curieux
de la regarder
je sens des choses qui enfin je crois ce
qui se passe qui se produisent c'est pas
toujours intéressé c'est voir ce qui est
au-delà de ce qu'on raconte les
commentateurs
après vous avez parlé des dirigeants je
vais le dire mais là ce qui n'est pas
encore arrivé à la surface les gens
qu'on connaît pas
comme je l'écoute je pense immédiatement
à François Mitterrand j'ai l'impression
d'entendre mon oncle François Mitterrand
dans la manière dont il décrit le
changement de monde la manière dont il
aborde avec curiosité sans préjugés et
dans la manière même dont il l'expose à
son interlocutrice j'ai vraiment
l'impression de retrouver le François
Mitterrand qui était en face de lui et
avec qui ils ont fait des émissions
mémorables mémorables et c'est d'autant
plus frappant en regardant cela que on
voit bien qu'il est là marqué par la
maladie comme était François Mitterrand
lorsqu’il va répondu et ces deux
émissions souhaitent quatre émissions je
sais plus combien il y en on peut les
regarder on peut les regarder pendant
pendant vraiment longtemps même si on
n'aime pas François Mitterrand on peut
parler tellement de François Mitterrand
tellement c'est absolument passionnant
jusque dans la manière d'ailleurs dont
François Mitterrand toujours politique
et ce qui certaines des réponses qu'il
aurait pu faire et la manière dont
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach le cerne il
revient mais en même temps notamment
pendant une heure il revient à la charge
effectivement il tourne autour des
François Mitterrand entre la culture et
la résilience qui sont quand même deux
aspects essentiels de la vie politique
qu'il a amené dans cette maison et qu'il
a imposé contre des gens qui peut-être
n'étaient pas d'accord mais a vraiment
imposé entre la culture et la résilience
il y avait entre lui et François
Mitterrand au-delà des conflits
politiques il y avait une réelle
connivence et complicité alors écoutez
ce que justement Jean-Pierre Elkabbach
disait de sa relation plutôt de ce qu'il
a appris de François Mitterrand on est
en mai 9 mai 2011 donc pour les 30 ans
de la victoire du président socialiste
de nouveau Jean-Pierre Elkabbach j'ai
appris je pense
la simplicité la résistance à la
médisance aura-gots aux rumeurs ne pas
en être impressionné ou intimidé ne
jamais aboyer avec ce qu'aboit ne jamais
poursuivre la meute je dirais comme lui
je parle pas des chiens parce que on est
même sévère avec les chiens
j'ai appris le respect de l'autre en
toutes circonstances Matthieu croissanto
faut rappeler quand même sa relation
avec François Mitterrand ça commence il
se fait virer de la télévision parce que
on le jugeait trop proche de Valéry
Giscard exactement il se met pas il
s'aimait pas enfin François Mitterrand
c'était pas du tout un de ces
journalistes proches et quand la gauche
arrive au pouvoir et ben Jean-Pierre
Elkabbache dit-il raconte-t-il lui-même
se fait débarquer pour raison politique
comme s'il y avait une chasse aux
sorcières dans les médias à cette époque
et en fait ça va amuser François
Mitterrand précisément de se confier à
Jean-Pierre Elkabbache qui n'est pas un
de ses courtisans qui n'est pas parmi
ses proches avec qui s'instaure une
relation de confiance fascination
j'allais dire un peu réciproque il y a
une grande fascination de Jean-Pierre
Elkabbache pour François Mitterrand mais
il y a aussi de l'autre côté une
fascination pour cette animal médiatique
qui a résisté qui a connu tous les
présidents et du coup il y a ce qui est
une immense culture politique parce que
François Mitterrand a respecté aussi les
interviews qui savaient qui savaient de
quoi il parlait et qui pouvait
s'inscrire dans le dans le temps long et
donc c'est une forme de de revanche en
fait ils se sont trouvés sur le targe
envie de dire et ils ont c'est vrai
partager ce que ce que décrivait
Frédéric
à l'adversaire que vous confiez le feu
qui vous anime c'est à dire que parler à
Jean-Pierre Elkabbach c'était pas parlé
à n'importe quel autre journaliste c'est
évidemment à celui-là qui était à sa
mesure qu'il pouvait en quelque sorte
délivrer son testament donc ça veut dire
François Mitterrand qui qui va le
rechercher en quelque sorte je ne sais
pas les détails le dit dans son livre
son livre de mémoire qui est sorti
l'année dernière il parle très bien de
cette période il montre qu'en fait le
feed avec François Mitterrand ne s'est
jamais rompu entre lui et François
Mitterrand après 80 et que même
Mitterrand s'amuse en disant mais vous
savez c'est pas moi et qu'en vérité si
on reprend l'exemple de France
Télévisions Jean-Pierre Elkabbach de
mémoire est nommé comme président de
France Télévisions c'est une nomination
très politique à l'époque en 93 et en 93
c'est l'objet d'un accord entre François
Mitterrand président et Édouard Balladur
Premier ministre donc ce que l'on voit
comme pour le grand public tout d'un
coup tiens ils sont réconciliés autour
de cette entretien en réalité c'est un
film qui s'est noué entre eux durant
toutes ces années là et qui était
important encore une fois dans les
mémoires de Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il en
parle beaucoup il y attire beaucoup
d'intention il en dit beaucoup de choses
alors ça ça ouvre un dernier tel il nous
reste quelques minutes et je voudrais
qu'on termine là-dessus sur les
questions de connivence de proximité
comment un journaliste politique réussi
à trouver la bonne distance finalement
avec les personnages qui le côtoient
écoutez tient Gérard Larcher qui raconte
ces petits déjeuners avec Jean-Pierre
Elkabbach qui précède l'interview
le petit déjeuner qui précédait
l'interview était un moment étonnant en
général il est il était au chemise et
comme il avait toujours froid il avait
une espèce de doudoune par dessus sans
branche nous partageions un café un
croissant nous discutions et il essayait
de nous sonder au-delà de ce que nous
avions envie soit de dire soit ce qui
était dans notre tête quelque part il
était un explorateur de nos pensées un
explorateur de nos pensées la critique
sur la connivence
il voulait absolument
il voulait absolument sortir le maximum
de chacun de ces interlocuteurs puis
vous savez vous pouvez pas être dompteur
si vous n'avez pas les lions donc il
faut quand même un certain moment avoir
une proximité cette proximité ne veut
pas dire une amitié ça ne veut pas dire
une une
mais ça veut dire une proximité
nécessaire
il aimait effectivement profondément les
politiques il était intéressé par
l'action politique par l'action publique
et il avait surtout envie de faire des
coups journalistiques c'était ça qui
l'animé Mathieu l'a dit tout à l'heure
voilà quand on sortait d'une émission
c'était est-ce que est-ce que l'urgence
de la FP est tombé est-ce que la dépêche
AFP qui à l'époque était le Graal les
réseaux sociaux n'existaient pas voilà
il fallait avoir sa dépêche AFP à la
sortie
voilà tout ça était un jeu il
rencontrait plusieurs fois les
politiques avant une interview pour
savoir exactement quand elle est sortie
une information et voilà et les
programmé ce jour là pour sortir
et je vais vous poser la même Mathieu de
bonnes distances avec les politiques
vous la vivez vous aussi c'est-à-dire
que pour avoir des infos il faut être en
confiance et en même temps il faut pas
il faut pas trop de connivence il avait
quelque chose de différent c'est sa
longévité une certaine façon la
longévité ça vous protège de la
connivence parce que vous vous devez pas
votre poste à quelqu'un qui vous le vous
en défaire de deux ans plus tard
Jean-Pierre Elkabbache c'était un
monument alors oui je le disais tout à
l'heure il avait ses chouchous oui il
avait les gens qu'il avait dans le nez
mais moi j'invite puisqu'on parlait des
vieilles émissions ou des émissions plus
anciennes à regarder car sur table parce
que ça permet de parler aussi d'Alain
Duhamel parce qu'il formait sans doute
un des meilleurs duo qu'on ait vu
d'interviewer politique extraordinaire
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'il y avait il y avait partenariat
alors était-il rodé était-il plus ou
moins involontaire je pense pas
il s'était trouvé l'un et l'autre aussi
toute leur vie et le hasard fait que je
voyais ce matin du ML très bien
évidemment j'ai changé avec lui et ce
qui m'a frappé dans le livre de
Jean-Pierre camache de mémoire c'est
qu'il parle énormément du Jean-Pierre
Elkabbache interviewer d'hommes
politiques et finalement très peu de la
partie dirigeante et je me suis
interrogé pourquoi j'ai posé la question
à Jean-Pierre qui m'a fait une réponse
qui n'était pas une réponse qui
permettait de comprendre et en fait en
discutant avec un aDML je pense que la
vraie réponse c'est qu'il a au fond
plutôt voulu que reste de lui l'image du
Grand interviewer politique plutôt que
celle du dirigeant de média où il en
avait rêvé où il avait fait des choses
formidables mais où finalement il avait
été sans doute beaucoup plus moins
heureux disons mais avec voilà et
finalement peut-être blessé par les
épreuves qu'il avait dû traverser merci
à tous et donc je rappelle qu'on va
pouvoir retrouver Jean-Pierre elkabbaj
dans l'émission un monde un regard que
Rebecca F est aussi lui avait consacré à
voir ce vendredi 6 octobre à 17h30 je
peux pas quand même c'était un exercice
très particulier cette émission j'ai
fait beaucoup de choses dans ma
thérapeutique mais jamais une émission
avec mon patron et ma directrice de
l'information donc voilà j'ai aussi
coché cette case merci à tous d'y avoir
participé